mais des combattants se parler
aujourd'hui on va se parler de ce
produit là vous l'avez vu dans le titre
c'est écrit on parlera du samsung galaxy
s 21
ultra le plus gros modèle de la gamme
plus gros modèles way est celui qui fait
le plus de promesses aussi avec une
fiche technique sur loup c'est avec le
dernier processeur exynos et le 2100
avec des appareils photos absolument
incroyable et surtout compatible avec un
style est issu de la gamme notes ou
alors d'une tablette samsung équipée
d'un stylet on va tous se regarder
aujourd'hui si ce nouveau samsung galaxy
s 21
ultra est intéressant s'il est fait pour
vous s'il faut l'acheter quelles sont
ses forces quelles sont ses faiblesses
et vous allez voir qu'on va pas être au
bout de nos surprises parce que j'ai
plein de choses à vous raconter plein de
choses plein plein plein plein mais
juste après ça gêne quand sa rage comme
ça alors aujourd'hui on va se concentrer
sur son nouveau smartphone de samsung
samsung galaxy s 21 ultra les noms sont
toujours un rallonge au niveau des
smartphones mais en tout cas est le plus
important c'est d'avoir un smartphone
qui est cool qui tient la route qui fait
plein de très jolies promesses et savoir
s'il était alors je sais pas avant toute
chose vous est ce que c'est un produit
que vous comptez acheter c'est un
produit qui pourrait vous intéresser
est ce que vous l'avez d'ailleurs déjà
précommandé marqué le moba en
commentaire je suis très curieux de
savoir et si ce n'est pas le samsung
galaxy s 21 ultra est ce le samsung
galaxy s 21
est ce le samsung galaxy s 21 plus
mettait le temps d'une petite pause
marquée moi ça en bas en commentaire
voir un petit peu si ce smartphone peut
vous intéresser ou alors pas du tout à
ce moment là quel smartphone vous
comptez acheter si vous en achetez un
voile avait compris un petit peu
l'histoire à les expose aux lilas c'est
bon c'est fait ok alors je vais tout
vous dire vous savez il ya plusieurs
usages qu'on va venir un petit peu
détaillées pour essayer de comprendre si
ce smartphone est fait pour vous le
premier usage va être usages multimédia
c'est à dire revenir jouer à des jeux
venir regarder des films des séries en
streaming quelle que soit la plateforme
venir naviguer aussi sur vos différents
réseaux sociaux ça peut être instagram
c'est peut-être youtube pour regarder
notamment les vidéos de monsieur gros et
ça c'est super d'ailleurs à ce sujet là
pensez à vous abonner
donc ça c'est vraiment usage gérer
aujourd'hui usage principal qu'on a sur
un smartphone c'est lusage multimédia ça
veut donc dire qu'il faut s'intéresser à
la qualité de la dalle voir si l'écran
est de bonne qualité bien fabriquer de
bonne facture et toute la partie
diot qu'on va venir examiner est-ce que
l'audio est à la hauteur sur ce
smartphone là et puis bien évidemment ce
qui va en découler c'est toute la partie
performance est ce que le nouveau exynos
2100 est à la hauteur tout en sachant
aussi que vous avez en plus soit 12 soit
16 giga de ram
le général signale pas trop mal on a de
la paix dès hier cinq performances
on va donc regarder tout ça et puis
après l'autre usage est extrêmement
important qui sont l'adn de cette gamme
s chez samsung c'est toute la partie
photo vidéo est-ce que ce smartphone
tient ses promesses ou pas et vous allez
voir c'est très intéressant c'est
vraiment extrêmement intéressant et
parfois que déroutant mais ça vous en
parle un tout petit peu plus loin donc
vous saurez tout mais aussi la partie
autonomie qu'on va développer un donc
beaucoup de points je vous invite donc à
venir visionner cette vidéo jusqu'au
bout pour tout savoir parce que oui
parce que oui il ya beaucoup de choses à
voir
on va commencer tout de suite par la
partie multimédia alors je sais pas si
vous le savez mais c'est vrai que
samsung est un des leaders au niveau des
écrans au niveau des dalles notamment
jeudi notamment sur smartphone au
travers de leur filiale samsung display
il faut savoir que samsung font dit
énormément de constructeurs dans le
monde entier divers et variés il ya
samsung également rédigé bref mais voilà
samsung est un acteur principal et
autant vous dire qu'une fois de plus là
dessus ils ont vraiment très très très
très bien bossé avec une dalle qui est
vraiment très très bon récit sur le
deuil de mick amoled 2 x qui est la
dernière génération dalle extrêmement
bien calibré très très bien maîtrisé
comme en laissant une technologie oled
c'est de la molette cdu oled la couleur
noire correspond à pixels et annonce qu
on appellera ici du contraste infini
le rendu des couleurs est vraiment à la
hauteur pour moi ce qui est important
dans les paramètres c'est effectivement
de laisser la fluidité des mouvements de
la nappe tati vous pouvez donc pousser
jusqu'à 120 hertz pour avoir toujours
plus de fluidité ça ça marche vraiment
bien si vous venez notamment joué à des
jeux qui vont jusqu'en 120 hertz et bien
vous avez une vraie belle fluidité c'est
pas nouveau on le sent vert on avait
déjà l'année dernière
par contre ce qui est intéressant ici
c'est que vous avez du sang rien du wqs
des plus on vous poussez la résolution
avant vous pousser l'expérience à fond
vous avez donc une dalle qui est super
mais calibrée très bien maîtrisée des
couleurs qui sont parfaitement justes
donc l'expérience de visionnage purement
et simplement pour vos yeux pour moi
elle est vraiment top
vous avez en plus après beaucoup
d'options notamment une protection du
confort visuel que je vous conseille de
venir enclenché pour éviter de vous
flinguer les yeux c'est beaucoup plus
reposant pour vos yeux et notamment
lorsque le soir vous allez regarder des
films des séries naviguer c'est quand
même beaucoup mieux ça m'a évité de
repousser l'endormissement
d'ailleurs j'en ai déjà parlé dans une
précédente vidéo des problèmes
d'endormissement lié aux smartphones
qu'on va utiliser le soir et un petit
peu trop et toutes ces questions de
lumière bleue de production de
mélatonine vous renvoie une fois de plus
à la vidéo mais là dessus et ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que la dalle elle est
vraiment bien maîtrisée donc très très
très bon extrêmement important dans
toute cette partie là c'est la partie
audio ici vous avez des hauts parleurs
stéréo haut parleurs qui se situe sur la
tranche en bas mais également haut
parleurs qui se situe juste en le par
lors que vous avez en eau en fait c'est
le haut par là vous avez utilisé lorsque
vous allez passer vos appels
téléphoniques alors je trouve ça très
bien vraiment très très bien très très
juste
j'aurais aimé qu'ils aillent aussi loin
que ce qu'on a pu retrouver sur
différents smartphones notamment trouvé
retrouvé l'année dernière chez shiomi
avec son mii dix pros c'est à dire à
bord exactement la même sortie audio sur
le bas que sur le haut ça vous permet
d'avoir un vrai son spatialisé avec le
même volume à droite et à gauche c'est
plus immersif va beaucoup plus loin
ici c'est pas le cas c'est un petit
point de regret puisque déjà
l'expérience est très bonne on sent un
petit déséquilibre entre les hauts
parleurs de droite qui va être plus
puissant plus performants et celui de
gauche
néanmoins néanmoins et ça c'est très
important il faut le préciser vous avez
une très très bonne qualité audio jours
pour me regarder des films des séries
regardez monsieur comme sur youtube une
fois de plus c'est tout ce que vous
voulez vous ne serez absolument pas déçu
ici vous le savez pas deux prises jack
elle a disparu déjà depuis un petit
moment vous pouvez venir connecter par
contre vos galaxie buzz pro dont je vous
ai déjà parlé que je vous recommande que
sont vraiment très très très bon je vous
renvoie de fait plus à la vidéo sur les
samsung galaxy bugs pro que vous avez
notamment en précommande offert avec le
samsung galaxy s 21 ultra et uniquement
avec le samsung galaxy s 21 ultra donc
ça c'est un superbe accueil de ces super
intéressant et puis d'airial dernier
point qu'on va se poser si c'est la
question de la performance
et puis je puis vous assurer qu ici la
performance est au rendez vous déjà la
première chose que je veux dire
remarquer c'est que en jouant bout d'un
moment je ne sens pas particulièrement
de chauffe eau de mon smartphone une
très très bonne répartition de la
chaleur je n'ai pas un processeur qui va
venir chauffer qu'on n'a pas poussé à
fond dans ses retranchements déjà ça
c'est vraiment très très très bon point
ensuite deuxième point et non des
moindres il est performant
sanou lac pas ça ne rame pas je n'ai pas
encore les retours du stade ragone 888
donc je peux pas vous dire
si les xenos 2100 est meilleur que le
sien dragon 888 même si d'avoir ma
petite idée là-dessus je n'ai pas de
données chiffrées donc aujourd'hui je ne
suis pas en capacité de vous le dire
néanmoins ce que je peux vous dire est
ce qui est sûr c'est que si vous voulez
acheter si vous avez déjà acheté ou pré
commander le samsung galaxy s 21 ultra
eh bien vous ne serez absolument pas
déçu par la performance cet exil aux
2100 dont vous pouvez y aller les yeux
fermés
il est fluide il répond très bien quoi
faire du multitâche si vous le souhaitez
je suis pas sûr qu'on passe du
multitâche là dessus mais si vous voulez
vous pouvez le faire et en termes de
capacités de calcul
il a vraiment ce qu'il faut sous le
capot c'est toujours une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec rhinochill
d'avoir un très beau smartphone c'est
bien mais il faut également de protéger
pour éviter de l'abîmé vous en douterez
à leur chéri nauche il ya beaucoup de
choix
vous avez notamment le taux japonais en
a tellement faut que je retrouve au lit
utiliser les solides sud de rideau
chiffres qui sont des coquilles vont
venir protéger votre smartphone contre
les chutes david allez voir sur le site
de rhinau si vous avez 5 % de remise
avec le code gros qui est tout en bas
les jetables petit coup d'oeil dans la
description vous avez des coques hunter
hunter fortnight vous avez même des
coques chicago bulls vous avez beaucoup
beaucoup de choses personnellement tout
ça très cool pour lire personnaliser à
votre convenance pour avoir des cop très
très très sympa regardez-moi ça là bas
c'est tout mignon si vous avez également
les crashs garde les mots des knicks qui
vont venir entourer votre smartphone si
vous voulez voir la face avant est la
face arrière est bien comme ça vous
allez venir l'entouré le protéger sur
les côtés très facilement contenir les
customiser
il ya plein de possibilités chéri nos jt
c'est très très très sympa plein de
couleurs différentes une seule puce vous
invite à les jeter un petit coup d'oeil
si vous avez bien sûr les protections
d'écran
quand même utilisé quand il fait chaud
l'été pour faire un petit peu devant des
protections d'écran qui vont dire
renforcer la protection votre écran et
le protéger d'un évidemment contre les
chutes les rayures tout ça vous en
douterez il ya beaucoup de solutions
énormément donc une fois de plus le lien
draps discutons et si vous voulez aller
beaucoup plus loin ça chauffe ça très
très cool parce que vous avez en
complément de ces jolies petites bêtes
là ou bien vous avez des docks sont
complètement personnalisée par analyse
abl vous allez ici league of legends
vous allez également retrouver regarder
mossala
c'est très sympa différents motifs
différents couleur pouvait bien
complètement les personnaliser vous en
avez bien évidemment pour le nouveau
samsung galaxy s 21 où vous en avez
aussi pour un des smartphones de plein
de marques différentes une fois de plus
de 8 à les jeter un petit coup d'oeil
dans la description vous avez un code
qui va y avoir une réduction de 5 % sur
tous les achats vous allez faire sur
site chez rhinochill et ça c'est très
cool ce qui est aussi important c'est
l'autonomie si vous avez une très grosse
batterie de 5000 millions terreur vous
allez pouvoir emmener loin dans le temps
est à dire une journée et demie à deux
jours une plus en fonction de vous et de
vos usages c'est un peu le point négatif
c'est fait de ne pas avoir de charger de
25 watts inclus ici dans la boîte vous
le savez j'ai déjà expliqué lorsque je
vous ai présenté ce smartphone ya
quelques jours donc si vous avez déjà un
chargeur 25 watts utilisable avec le
smartphone vous pouvez utiliser son
problème sinon vous pouvez l'acheter
directement sur le site de samsung
bon ok pourquoi pas autre point non des
moindres avec l'expérience logiciels et
se tourne sur wayne lui ait trois points
comme les versions précédentes de vonn
eu à l'expérience est vraiment
complètement optimisé personnellement
j'aime beaucoup celle de mes expériences
préféré sur android claire lisible on a
les options qu'il faut au bon endroit on
comprend tout si vous cherchez une très
bonne expérience android vous pouvez
aller sans aucun problème sur les
nouveaux smartphones de samsung même sur
les aberrations précédente avec one way
ça marche très très bien puisque je vous
parlais pas forme ans et un autre qui
est extrêmement intéressant qui est
arrivé cette année c'est la
compatibilité avec les espèces les
espèces sont les styles et de samsung
alors qu'est-ce que vous permet de faire
se respecte il vous permet effectivement
est bien de venir à noter de venir
naviguer de venir faire des petits
dessins des croquis tout ce qu'on
pouvait faire avec un respect de
maintenance que vous ne pouvez pas faire
avec ces aspects là ce sont les airs
jester le fait d'avoir des gestes pour
commander votre smartphone en bluetooth
et bien ça vous ne pouvez pas pourquoi
parce que vous n'avez pas la possibilité
ici de le connecter en bluetooth vous
pouvez pas leurs charges et donc vous
allez pouvoir utiliser comme un style et
un peu plus standard on va enlever ces
options qui sont somme toute assez sympa
d'ailleurs je sais pas si tout le monde
les utilise c'est à dire pouvoir
utiliser notamment pour déclencher votre
appareil photo à distance bon là ça vous
pouvez pas le faire néanmoins
l'expérience pour venir naviguer pour
venir dessiner pour faire des croquis
pour l'utiliser comme sur n'importe quel
samsung galaxy note 20 par exemple eh
bien vous avez une très très bonne
expérience maintenant la question qui se
pose c'est est-ce vraiment intéressant
d'utiliser un aspect de ce samsung
galaxy ace matin ultra on est sur un
usage qui est très nicher et les
personnes qui veulent vraiment un stylet
pour coter productivité pour le côté
illustrations dessins et prise de notes
je pense qu'ils iront plutôt sur une
gamme note traduit si vous venez sur le
s 21
ultra vous voulez acheter un style ex
quelque chose qui vous intéresse si vous
avez un très gros usage au niveau de la
photo et de la vidéo puisque ici la
gamme mais c'est une gamme usage photo
vidéo mais que la partie productivité
notamment style était très importante
mais là une fois de plus on s'adresse
vraiment à très peu de personnes c'est
très riche et elle a utilisé en espagne
sur un samsung galaxy s 21 litres à je
suis pas sûr que ça intéresse beaucoup
de monde d'ailleurs dit man vous ça
pourrait vous intéresser un banc
commencé vraiment que de le voir parce
que j'ai pas persuadé alors après ça
marche bien c'est sympa expérience est
bonne tout un party de productivité pour
venir travailler
grâce à l'exo ce 2100 au sun ra
parfaitement bien donc de ce point de
vue là aussi soyez rassurez vous aura
absolument aucun problème maintenant sur
la question des usages du espagne là
dessus bon on verra l'avenir
maintenant on va se concentrer sur le
pont les plus intéressants c'est toute
la partie photo vidéo et c'est l'atout
que j'ai plein de choses à vous dire
la toute première chose à savoir c'est
qu'ici je n'ai pas un smartphone que
vous pourrez retrouver dans le commerce
on est sur une version de pré production
c'est à dire qu'il y aura
potentiellement des différences entre
vous ce que vous allez acheter dans le
commerce si vous souhaitez l'acheter et
moi le smartphone que j'ai reçu et que
la presse entière a reçu aujourd'hui à
cet instant t donc ça c'est important il
faut le savoir
rassurez-vous ce seront les mêmes
capteurs ce sera la même chose d'un
point de vue purement matérielles mais
il se peut qu'il y ait un petit
modifications ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point qui est le plus
important c'est que il va arriver c'est
sûr et certain des sites très peu de
temps des mises à jour logicielles que
je n'ai pas aujourd'hui et c'est ça qui
est pour moi tout cas aujourd'hui le
point le plus important
et quel point peut bloquant de ce test
néanmoins je dois vous en parler
aujourd'hui parce que ce smartphone
repart puisqu'il doit être prêtés à
d'autres médias donc c'est normal c'est
la règle du jeu
donc ce que vous allez voir aujourd'hui
est ce que vous montrez c'est une photo
à un instant t de ski ce smartphone sans
prendre en compte les mises à jour que
vous aurez vous potentiellement qui
voudront corriger les points négatifs en
tout cas que je viens retenir là dessus
alors il ya plein de points positifs
mais il ya aussi des points négatifs qui
m'empêche d'avoir une version
complètement définitive sur toute la
partie photo de ce sparks vous allez
vous montrer les qualités et les défauts
fur et à mesure leur nez sur le capteur
principal ça marche très bien voyons la
très bonne gestion au niveau de la
lumière va bien le détail du ciel on
voit bien le fond la cathédrale on voit
aussi les zones sombres en termes de
gestion
de luminosité dans l'ensemble ça marche
très très bien on a un petit peu de
bruit sur le côté voyez ça c'est des
premiers petits points venir remarquez
on passe sur l'ultra grand temps une
fois de plus sa gestion de la lumière au
niveau des nuages de détail le hdr tout
ça ça marche très très bien vraiment
super bien des maux niveau i de la flac
ici ça s'est super bien on vient se
rapprocher ensuite en x 2 ça va pas trop
mal mais ça commence un peu alice et
c'est le défaut que je vais repéré ici
c'est d'un point de vue logiciel et vous
le verrez tout aulong salissent on le
voit ici au niveau du panneau on le voit
ici sur le mur alors qu'on est en x 2
ont continué sciences et en x 4 on dit
sur le premier était l'objectif
ça va venir lit c'est un petit peu et on
le voit ici on continue ensuite on
arrive en x 10 c'est très lisse et un
pouvoir compter sur le deuxième thé
l'objectif d'un tel objectif avec un
zoom optique x 10
et bien voyez ça commence à l'iss et ça
c'est pas compréhensible c'est tout le
problème du traitement logiciel là
dessus qu'il va falloir venir corriger
que voudrait tout au long de ce test
vous voyez ici est notamment aussi au
niveau du lampadaire ses traits lissés
c'est très très bizarre très très très
bizarre on continue ensuite en x 36
alice et ça c'est pas anormal mais un
petit peu beaucoup et on va jusqu'au x
100 il ya des c'est un petit peu whaou
blessés très lisse et pour prendre la
même chose ici très très très bonne
gestion de la plage dynamique on voit
vraiment au niveau du ciet ça c'est
vraiment top c'est vraiment très très
très beau très très bien maîtrisé mais
une fois de plus je trouve lycées sont
peut-être la principale j'ai
l'impression que ces lycées mais mission
lgv au niveau du ciel c'est très bizarre
pas c'est très très très très bizarre
luttera grand-angle par un petit peu le
sait je me sens quelle espèce de petit
effet voyez un peu trop lisse et
logiciels c'est vraiment vraiment
bizarre on continue aussi ensuite x 2 x
4 regardez là les contours là on le voit
ici pour voir qu'on dit quand x 4 c'est
très très bizarre x 10g tous ses
contours là qui sont l'issue d'un point
de vue logiciel je suis sur un
téléobjectif avec un zoom optique x 10
donc c'est très surprenant x 30
il ya un effet wow c'est très sympa et
on se re continue jusqu'au foie sans bon
bah là il ya du bruit c'est normal c'est
le poisson c'est l'effet waouh mais
c'est normal continue ici voyez le ciel
gestion de la lumière ça c'est top
continue ultra grand temps que ça
fonctionne x 2 ça commence à l'itie on
le voit notamment au niveau de la ligne
d'horizon ici x 2
x 4 c'est la même chose salissent le
traitement est très bizarre faut 10 x 30
bon c'est pas terrible et le poisson on
oublie que c'est sûr de se marrer sur un
contre jour une fois de plus ça marche
ne sera plus très très très très bien
c'est la balle
le très beau travail qui a été fait on
voit le soleil va bien les nuages
à côté on est une très bonne la gestion
des nuages aussi au fond assez super
super vaud on voit bien la place qui
éclaire et on voit bien également le mur
ici qu'on devrait probablement pas avec
d'autres smartphones par contre c'est
lisse et une fois de plus ça c'est le
fil rouge à vous allez voir on retrouve
partout même sur du très grand angle et
superbe maîtrise à c'est vraiment super
bien
s'il n'y avait pas ce problème de
lissage ça serait très très bien on
continue ici avec le x 2 le x 4 une fois
de plus c'est très bien des sévices et
c'est dommage on continue avec le x 10
le x 30 et le foie sans voyez c'est les
mêmes reproches que je vais faire un
petit peu tout le temps
quelques photos prises à l'intérieur
bien que cette raison on a quand même
beaucoup de lumière et ça c'est plutôt
bien on vient au mais la qualité est là
ça ça fonctionne bon alors se rapproche
un peu c'est un petit peu moins bon là
je suis prêt à me faire couper les
cheveux vous me direz on s'en fiche et
par zoom pas mal alors ces lycées les
contours sont pas terribles toujours le
même problème mais quand même un petit
effet whaou même s'il faudrait quand
même venir améliorer un petit peu tout
ça on continue aussi sur quelques
petites fautes aux côtés chez mon pote
qui a le bar le mayerling à clermont
ferrand ont comme sa principale ok
l'ultra grand angle est quand même
plutôt bien pas déformante très bonne
gestion de la lumière d'être plus c'est
la très bien on vient se rapprocher
enfin du ok pourquoi pas on voit qu'on
commence un petit peu alice et honda du
bruit ici sur le faut car c'est très
bizarre on continue ici en x 10 mai me
remarque un x 30 et fois sans lasser le
mode single take a qu'une fois quelques
photos bon single take c'est assez
rigolo se permet d'abord différents
rendus bon voilà c'est un peu gadget ça
va jouer sur la couleur je suis la
lumière ça va jouer sur des mouvements
ça vous permet en faisant juste une
vidéo de 5 à 15 secondes de sortir
différentes photos de différentes
manières des vidéos bon c'est rigolo
le mode porte qu'alors mode portrait
c'est assez intéressant là j'ai fait le
mode portait sur le capteur principal ça
des tours plutôt pas mal
je le vois au niveau des doigts et vous
dire qui relatait m6 donc ça c'est quand
même relativement normal mais dès que je
passe sur l'autre avec luttera
grand-angle regardez ici là entre les
doigts et bien là il a eu du mal et ça
c'est un petit peu surprenant quand même
une fête plus pour voir que j'ai un
laser deuxième photo pour vérifier alors
là il est venu corriger le haut mais
j'ai une petite partie entre mc et est
un peu plus dur ici également
ça a été un peu plus dur
la forme des doigts là ici est un peu
bizarre je pense à cause de la couleur
du fond je m'attendais à ce que ce soit
beaucoup mieux fait est là pour moi
voyez c'est pas complètement par fait et
c'est un petit peu dommage
quelques petites photos de nuit alors
que petite photo de lui vous allez
forcément récupérer un petit peu en
bruitages puis les défauts de lissage de
les retrouver capteur principal luttera
grand temps devient moins apprécié n'est
pas stabilisé la nuit dont bon fois pas
terrible pas terrible en continuant bien
se rapprocher tout doucement pourquoi
pas voyez plus on zoome et plus on perd
et ça c'est normal je dirais que sinon
ce qui est pas mal et vous le voyez ici
c'est wii noire donc c'est très
compliqué car il faut tenir parce que
nous sommes en plein couvre-feu je veux
faire une attestation pourra l'aider à
faire quelques petites photos je raconte
pas l'histoire ça vient me ressortir un
petit peu le ciel pourquoi pas c'est pas
mal à ce que je vais regretter ici c'est
que les espèce d'aberration prennent de
gestion de lumière au niveau des
lampadaires vous riez j'ai tous contours
là là c'est pas terrible et c'est un
petit peu dommage l'idée sinon est pas
mal dans la gestion la lumière au niveau
du ciel et pour la partie éclairée en
bas est plutôt bien sûr les éclairages
parce que j'ai un regret et et surtout
que ça lisse un petit peu pour ça ce
n'est pas complètement surprenant nous
traquerons entende on oublie on peut se
rapprocher un peu mais une fois de plus
c'est pas extraordinaire
las de ce côté-là ça c'est assez
aberrant fait c'est pas terrible alors
on devine un petit peu la une aussi
dessus par contre j'ai espèce
d'aberration là je sais pas ce que c'est
la gestion de la lumière est pas
terrible à c'est un petit peu trop
éclairé ils demandent à y avoir une
petite correction logicielle ici pour
avoir un très très beau résultat avril à
partie aussi du aulas est pas
extraordinaire fois de plus je vous le
dis et je le redis nous faut une petite
petite mise à jour logicielle pour venir
corriger tous ces points là l'ultra
grand angle on oublie c'est horrible on
vient se rapprocher c'est pas terrible
ici on a un peu plus de lumière à ça
fonctionnera pas trop trop mal mais vrai
problème ici au niveau de la gestion des
éclairages publics un petit peu trop
lumière et bien ça ne veut pas céder
expo plus long grâce et probablement
aussi la raison vous avez l'expo entre 2
à 5 secondes en continu ici sur l'ultra
grand angle on oublie on peut se
rapprocher un petit peu si on veut mais
une fois de plus c'est pas fait pour et
la caméra de celle ci la nuit ok voilà
on peut mais bon il ya du bruit salies
c'est pas terrible je ne recommande pas
comme l'année dernière bouée filmé en 8k
jusqu'à 24 images par seconde ici
absolument aucune stabilisation
personnellement je ne vous recommande
pas je pense qu'aujourd'hui qui est
vraiment grand intérêt à bien filmé en
huit can à moi si vous souhaitez le
faire là lucas commencent à arriver donc
pourquoi pas posez le sur un trépied
mettez le sur un game bol si vous
la main c'est absolument mortels ce que
je vous recommande plutôt c'est de venir
filmer en 4k uhd à 60 images par seconde
avec une stabilisation
vous aurez un super vendu et qu'il ira
parfaitement bien pour un usage standard
toute la partie vidéo est plutôt bien
vous avez une bonne organisation
logiciel le rang d'une somme toute assez
qualitatif
il ya un nouveau mode qui par contre ne
convainc pas particulièrement c'est ce
qu'on appelle le vue du réalisateur
une fois de plus c'est traîner ça
s'adresse pas beaucoup de monde je ne
vois pas quel intérêt on va venir
utiliser cette vue du réalisateur alors
on peut venir l'utiliser si vous êtes pp
garcia parce qu'il filme avec un
smartphone de samsung lui seul je pense
on devrait cet usage mais au delà de lui
je pense pas grand monde pourquoi parce
que ça vous sort déjà un seul fichier
vous n'avez pas différents fichiers en
fonction des différents capteurs ce qui
pourrait en tout cas être intéressant
donc vous avez un seul fichier ce qu'on
appelle avec le picture in picture soit
vous avez votre caméra de celle ci en
grand et l'une de vos trois caméras
derrière en petit soit l'inversé des
trois caméras en grand et votre caméra
c'est le fion petit en plus de ça ce que
j'ai vraiment accroché c'est que vous
n'avez pas de stabilisation ça vient
probablement du limite de performance du
smartphone l'exynos 2100 et peut-être
limité en terme de calcul pour venir
vous stabiliser les images d'un point de
vue purement logicielle ce qui fait que
si je me retrouve à venir filmer comme
ça et que je le tiens la main surtout
chez moi ça bouge ça tremble c'est pas
terrible et l'expérience un peu gâchée
donc prévenir l'utiliser bien évidemment
sur un game boulot auquel cas vous
n'aurez absolument aucun problème
ou alors le mettre sur un trépied
pourquoi pas pour des interviews mais
une fois de plus avec du picture in
picture
voilà je pense qu'il ya besoin
d'évolution logiciel il ya besoin de
pouvoir extraire ces différents fichiers
indépendamment pourquoi pas pour pouvoir
faire des interviews vous avez vous et à
l'intervenant de l'autre côté ça
pourrait avoir un sens mais comme celle
là aujourd'hui c'est une étape
intermédiaire pour arriver vraiment
quelque chose d'intéressant de la même
manière la vidéo de nuit
voilà pour moi la vidéo de nuit c'est
pas terrible c'est très bruitée je pense
que ça vient effectivement d'une partie
logicielle après vous le savez la vidéo
elle a besoin de lumière vous n'avez pas
de lumière
avec la nuit c'est pas terrible on est
sur un smartphone bon il n'y a rien
d'étonnant nature sont bien résumé pour
avoir une vision globale
on a ici un excellent smartphone
performant on a une super d'halong très
très très bonne expérience pour toute la
partie multimédia on est une très bonne
autonomie on a un smartphone qui est
très cool espace officiel qui est
vraiment bien je suis persuadé je suis
convaincu qu'une mise à jour qui ne
saurait tarder va venir corriger ces
petits défauts en termes de photos et de
vidéos puisqu'on parle ici de défauts
logiciels et non pas de défaut matériel
il est évident que samsung va venir
corriger la copie très rapidement et je
suis persuadé qu'ils resteront un des
leaders en termes de photos sur
smartphone je regrette uniquement que le
produit que je suis aujourd'hui ne soit
pas complètement top pouvoir tout vous
montrer
mais une fois de plus et je reste
vraiment convaincu intimement convaincu
que ce smartphone tiendra ses promesses
en terme de photos pour conclure je vous
parlais du tarif
si vous ne les connaissez pas je voulais
relever un petit peu en tête vous avez
deux configurations soit 12 giga de ram
16 giga bram les 12 il ya un drame vous
allez pouvoir avec 128 go de stockage de
256 go de stockage donc douzy cadrin
plus 128 go de stockage et à 1259 euros
si vous voulez passer en 256 go de
stockage vous êtes à 1309 euros et 16
giga de ram 512 giga de stockage 1409
euro réfléchit c'est vraiment la
capacité de stockage dont vous avez
besoin puisque vous n'avez pas ici la
possibilité de rajouter une carte micro
sd pour rajouter du stockage pas là il
faut savoir tout ça voilà pour cette
vidéo de test global sur ce samsung
galaxy s 21 ultra dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas aux commentaires à
ce qu'il vous tente
est ce que pourrait vous tentez qu'est
ce que vous pensez toute la partie qui
est déjà abouti aujourd'hui la partie
écran la partie audio la partie
performance qu'est ce que vous pensez de
toute cette partie là qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la partie photo de la partie
vidéo marc et moi ça bien évidemment en
bas en commentaire quand on se retrouve
très vite on continua par l'état qui
continue à parler de samsung parce que
oui parce que oui il ya plein de belles
choses qui arrivent et ça c'est génial
des bisous l'amour qui a très vite ciao